>> ARE YOU TEMPTING FATE IF YOU
STAY UP TOO LATE?
THROUGH THIS SHOW MAKES YOU
SNICKER, BUT AT THE COST OF YOU
TICKER?
NU STUDY SAYS FOR OPTIMUM HEART
HEALTH USUALLY GO TO BED BETWEE
TEN AND 11:00 P.M., NOT A.M.,
EMILY.
RESEARCHER SAY YOUR RISK OF
HEART DISEASE GOES UP 12 PERCEN
IF YOU FALL ASLEEP AFTER 11 AND
THAT RISK INCREASES TO 25
PERCENT IF YOU GO TO BED
AFTER MIDNIGHT.
IF YOUR WEIGHT FOR FIVE DAYS
STRAIGHT, YOU'RE ON A BENDER
WITH KAT.
WHICH BY THE WAY, IT WAS NEVER
MENTIONED IN THE SONG AFTER
MIDNIGHT.
ONLY GOOD THINGS HAPPEN AFTER
REAGAN LAID ON THE LINE.
OTHER RISK FACTORS INCLUDE
STRESS, DEPRESSION, AND WORKING
FOR CUOMO.
RESEARCHERS WERE DO ANYTHING TO
AVOID TELLING AMERICANS TO LOSE
SLEEP.
THEY ARE KILLING THEMSELVES TO
WATCH THE SHOW.
WE HAVE THE BEST FANS.
YOU'LL ALL BE DEAD SOON, BUT I
HOPE IT WAS WORTH IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS,
KAT.
DO YOU FEEL GUILTY?
>> YES.
I THINK IT'S NORMAL, I'VE NEVER
BEEN TO BED BEFORE 11 WITHOUT
THE ASSISTANCE OF MEDICATION.
>> EXACTLY.
DOES ANYBODY DO THAT?
IF SO HOW.
I DON'T OWN.
I DON'T BUY IT, I DON'T THINK
IT'S REAL, I DON'T THINK THE
STUDY IS REAL.
>> I THINK EMILY, EMILY, I THIN
THAT SLEEPING AS A SKILL THAT
ONE HAS TO LEARN BECAUSE IF YOU
COULD FIND THE RIGHT WAY TO
SLEEP, YOUR WHOLE LIFE CHANGES.
IN MY RIGHT, EMILY?
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
TWO POINTS, NUMBER ONE, I FEEL
LIKE THE REASON THIS WORKS IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO GO TO BED
LATER ARE PROBABLY DOING A
HIGHER PROPORTION OF BAD THINGS
BUT EVERYTHING THEY REDUCE IT T
THE ONE DATA POINT THAN FORGET
EVERYTHING ELSE.
LIKE ARE YOU DOING LINES IN
EATING JAKE'S.
AND THEN ONE TIME, I MEET REAL
NOCTURNAL, SOMEONE WHOSE
INTERNAL BODY CLOCK SINCE
FOREVER SINCE THEY WERE A CHILD
THEY BECAME A DRIVER BECAUSE SH
WAS BASICALLY LIKE TO MY POINT
SHE SAID I WAS TRYING TO FORCE
MYSELF AGAINST MY SEPARATING
RHYTHM OR WHATEVER AND ONLY WHE
I BECAME A NIGHT DRIVER DID MY
WORLD LEVEL OUT.
IT'S A TRUE STORY.
>> WHERE IS SHE NOW?
>> IT'S ALL RIGHT.
IT WAS A GOOD STORY.
SO HOW IMPORTANT IS WHOSE LEAP
TO YOU?
>> AS AN ATHLETE, YOU ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO GET YOUR EIGHT HOURS SO IT
BECAME REALLY IMPORTANT, BUT WE
TEND TO STRETCH THE EIGHT HOURS
LIKE SAY TO GO I BET IT THREE,
GET UP IT TOO, SO AS LONG AS YO
GET YOUR EIGHT HOURS IN YOUR
GOOD.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE FULL EIGHT,
BUT AS YOU GET OLDER, WHEN
YOU'RE YOUNGER, YOU CAN BE A
LITTLE MORE WILD BUT AS YOU GET
OLDER, EVE GOT TO GET THAT, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ACTIVE YOU
HAVE.
>> THAT EIGHT HOURS AND.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A SKILL YOU
JUST AGAIN, THESE STUDIES GO,
THERE'S NO POINT TO THEM, IT'S
RIDICULOUS PRATE I FEEL LIKE
THIS KIMMEL AND GO BEAR, THEY
ARE LIKE LISTS AND COME OVER NO
SAYING DON'T WATCH, BUT IF YOU
DO, YOU'LL DIE.
>> GOOD STRATEGY.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET CHARGED A
A SERIAL KILLER, I WILL TESTIFY
TO BE CLEAR, IT'S NOT BECAUSE I
WANT YOU TO GO TO JAIL, IT'S
BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING.
>> I KNEW I COULD COUNT ON YOU.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I FEEL LIKE I WAS LIKE TWO
BECAUSE BASICALLY I WAS TOLD
THAT I WAS GOING TO BE TESTING
THEORY LIVE DURING YOUR SHOW AN
I TOOK SAVE IN AMBIEN ON THE WA
UP HERE AND I AM REALLY
STRUGGLING.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU JUST
ASKED ME.
>> I TEST SO MANY THINGS,
MELATONIN IS INTERESTING, BUT
YOU GET CRAZY NIGHTMARES.
LUDO SITS, THAT STUFF MAKES YOU
NUTS.
>> BEER IS GOOD.
>> BEER COMMITTEE WAKE UP TWO
HOURS LATER.
I GO TO AVOID BED TO AVOID THE
CONVERSATION.
LITERALLY, WANT TO HEAR ABOUT M
DAY?
HOW MANY GUYS PRETEND THERE
ASLEEP ON THE COUCH THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WATCH REALITY TV.